on the mercedes-benz vans phone line is
the head coach of the los angeles
chargers brandon staley how are you
coach i'm doing well rich thanks for
having me sorry to make you uh sit
through that promo material but i got to
keep the lights on you know what i'm
saying so
i do okay i'm sure you understand the
way the business works i respect that
thank you
so uh let's just jump into it um
something you would have signed for i
imagine before the the season is a
chance to make the playoffs or
maybe having it wrapped up by now what's
your two cents on on on playing in this
game come sunday night coach yeah i mean
we certainly wanted to be in a position
to compete for a championship compete uh
you know for a division championship
which we you know were able to do in
december is give ourselves a chance you
know because that's where it starts you
know in pro football and then um you
know certainly when you know we had that
tough one against kansas city and that
wasn't gonna go down for us then you
know you pivot to the next thing which
is um giving yourself a chance in the
tournament and that's the type of team
that we want to be around here and uh
now we've put ourselves in a position to
do that and um you know we're excited
for our opportunity this week and covet
19 man i mean talk about the things you
know coaches are control freaks and um
and control what you can control you
cannot control that how are your team
right now with this virus uh where now
um kovid can absolutely end a season
with games like this on the line yeah
right so i think i think as we've seen
throughout the league i think it just
hits teams at different points uh it hit
us you know at christmas you know for
the houston game where we kind of got
cleaned out and you know i think all of
us are learning a lot as we go and i
mean i think since i took the job in
january so much has changed with
protocols and you know the way this
virus is you know shape-shifted and
moved and i know the nfl is trying to
move with it and
i think that what we've tried to do is
stay connected as an organization and
you have to stay flexible and i think
over the last couple weeks you know
we've been
virtual in the morning make those
adjustments to limit the exposure and i
think all of us now have that you know
that experience with zoom in that world
and we're kind of comfortable in that
space so
last week we were virtual and our guys
handled it beautifully
made some alterations to the schedule
and um you know we had a really good
week of practice yesterday you know last
week and and played well so i think the
big thing rich is you have to be
connected as an organization because
things are going to move all the time
and you got to be able to move with it
and communicate well and i think all of
us in the nfl um are doing the best we
can i'm not being glib when i ask this
question in the manner in which i ask it
trust me but do you real do you tell
someone like justin herbert to say go
home don't go anywhere order in don't
glitter i'm serious like yeah no no it's
uh it's a point well taken i think um
you know we're trying to do the best we
can with every single player uh
especially you know the premium players
like justin that matter a lot to your
success it's very difficult to win
without your starting quarterback out
there so um you know justin is has been
taking all the necessary precautions we
haven't done anything extreme but i know
that um you know just following you know
the guidelines that um you know the cdc
and you know uh all the medical experts
have uh put in place with mass social
distancing washing your hands uh limit
exposure uh justin is you know obviously
following that to the fullest and um you
know i think we're all doing the best we
can and and i think that he's you know
done a good job and i think our team has
really handled it well um and i'm proud
of you know i think rich it's i'm proud
of the way we've handled it this season
because it's it hasn't been easy um but
um you know we're all in it together and
i think that's also an important point
is that um no matter what you're in nfl
what type of walk of life we're all in
it we all have kids that go to school
and things like that so we're doing the
best we can brandon staley la chargers
head coach here on the rich eisen show
so what what has been herbert's biggest
football challenge this year what
defenses are trying to do to him um and
what what what general sense he sees
when he gets to the line of scrimmage
and how he's been battling that
throughout his second season first with
you
yeah rich i think his biggest challenge
i think is just handling a new offense
this year uh and taking full command of
our offense and
i think the inventory of experience is
you know every time he plays against a
different defense he's able to bank that
experience and and grow from it and i
think what people you know forget about
guys like him is that he's still brand
new you know he's still seeing
defenses for the first time and uh and i
think what he's been able to do
throughout the season is improve uh his
command of our offense certainly and
i've just been so impressed with how
he's taking command of our offense and
and run with it and how much he's
improved from the beginning of the
season to now and then also banking on
you know these inventory of experiences
with different defenses and um you know
how people are playing us and how they
assess our team and learning that game
within the game
and he's just becoming a more complete
player every single time he goes out and
certainly one of the big reasons why
we're having the season we're having and
he's been fantastic all season for us
well in terms of running with it
literally i mean um the steeler game he
was stupendous he had to it sometimes i
guess but are you trying to keep him in
the pocket is that what you and joe
lombardi tell him don't do that um
because he's he's got that ability to be
a game changer with his legs as well
what's your philosophy on that i mean
taking the the job and and trying to you
know fit this offense for him we really
wanted to be able to get him on the move
you know with our rpo game our keeper
game which has been a very big strength
of ours you know uh getting him on the
move changing the launch point um so
defenses aren't teeing off i think
that's been a big strength of our
offense and then the one thing that he
has
that the most special quarterbacks do is
when that first play isn't there can
that second play become a big one and
he's shown that creativity and that
playmaking ability outside the pocket
whether it's throwing to you know moving
to throw the football
um in the deep part of the field or you
know that's how you make first downs
when it's crowded and there's traffic
can you can you move can you create
offense um and and that's something that
he does really well and then in the
pittsburgh game hey if they're gonna try
and take away all your receiving threats
play a lot of split safety man to try to
take away keenan and mike austin eckler
and everyone's backs turn now he has
real speed i mean this guy's a 4-6 guy
it's 6-6 240. so i think that we've done
a really good job of you know keeping
him out of harm's way but at the same
time utilizing those talents like you
mentioned um so that they have to defend
all 11 players on the field including
him and i think that's why we're having
the quality year that we're having
offensively brandon sally la chargers
head coach here on the rich eisen show i
i'm going to ask you a general question
and uh and i'm sure you've been asked it
many times but you i think you know
where i'm going with this even uh fourth
down calls what what is your you know
sometimes you you're taking some points
this week even you know on fourth and
inside the five against kansas city you
went for it on every single one of those
situations i know
it's all relative opponent score or
positioning but wha what is your process
in the heat of the moment where game
clock is ticking down play clock's
ticking down
and you make this decision
well i think we you know we go into the
game with you know initial models of how
uh you know assessing our opponent and
who's going to be available for the game
you know weather you know all that good
stuff you know you take all those into
consideration with your initial models
then at the game then you have the feel
of the game the flow of the game uh the
instinctive part of the game and that's
what we try to do is apply both
processes
and then treat each decision like they
have a life of their own and
that's what i believe is the best way um
and just because something goes well
doesn't mean that you're you know
playing with house money the next time
and just because it doesn't go well
doesn't mean that that should turn you
into someone that's uh reluctant to go
for it so we've tried to you know stay
in the moment and you know against
denver it was a possession game we were
playing against two backup quarterbacks
and our defense was playing at a really
high level and so you know
we wanted to make that a possession game
turn that into a two-score game turn it
into a three-score game
and that's what we did and we felt like
that was the best strategy for that game
other times um it has been different and
you know i think that when you have an
offense like ours you certainly want to
give them as many opportunities as
possible specifically our quarterback um
the mo the more chances that you give
justin um
to score the ball the better you know
your team is going to be and and i felt
like he's done a a fantastic job all
year and you can point to a lot of games
where um i feel like those decision
makings help you know helped us win and
i think we're getting better as we go um
but you know i think the big thing the
big you know i think theme is we're just
going to treat each one of them like
they have a life of their own and um i
think we're getting better as we go well
how do you handle like say the week
after the the chiefs game where all
those did in fact um mount up
how do you handle that personally yeah i
think i think being transparent with the
with the players and with the with with
you the media and our fans is um you
know process over result i mean um and
you know for instance in the first
kansas city game um a lot of those
decisions help us win that game and
i felt like our process was was good in
the second game
you know on the first drive we had done
the same thing you know two weeks before
against joe burrow on the you know that
that offense so prolific you know fourth
and fourth opening drive um you know we
go for it on fourth and fourth justin
hits keenan for a touchdown and really
kind of sent us on our way uh in a big
way in that game and um in kansas city
you know he hits donald in the back of
the end zone it's a beautiful throw and
catch and then we had that just you know
that tragic sort of ending to that play
but i mean that was good process that
was good um that was a good design um it
just didn't go down the one um you know
at the end of the half uh my mindset at
the end of the half against kansas city
was i felt like we had a chance to
separate you know you know 17 to 10 to
me um wasn't the type of separation that
i was looking for 21 to 10 was the type
of separation i was looking for they
were getting the ball at the beginning
of the second half um and you know i was
aware that like hey there's no field
position to be gained here you know
because this is the last play um but i
had a lot of confidence on our offense
versus their defense and um i know that
that's one of those decisions that um
was questioned and it should be but um
that was my mindset was to make that a
2110 two possession game
um and it just didn't go down so um you
know i feel like um you know rich that
um you know you have to be able to live
with your decisions and and be proud of
your process and and i think that's what
we've done all season long and um you
know i think it it's given us an
identity that our players can believe in
that our fans can believe in and um you
know i'm excited to continue it moving
forward well i've been at this uh with
the nfl network for 18 years doing this
show now this is my eighth year and i've
never asked the coach the question i'm
about to ask you brandon staley but
here we go um there is a circumstance i
i don't know if you are aware of it and
you might be because you're you're very
perceptive
that if the steelers win
and the colts lose
that both you and the raiders make the
playoffs if you tie
on sunday night football
and there are a lot of people talking
about this right now
and uh would you actually
willingly take a tie
when you know that that assures you of
making it and the other team
if you communicate with that other team
do something like that coach brandon
staley
yeah that's a pretty loaded scenario
there
you know like that is a all-time coffee
shop
scenario
uh i feel like i'm with my buddies at
the university of dayton or something
like that
um
uh you know i
i think we all respect the game and the
nfl shield and the integrity of this
game far too much to to you know
be complicit in something like that this
game matters too much to too many people
and we want to play our best and
be proud of the result one way or the
other and so
i know what we're going to do everything
we can to go win this game
and play the way we're capable playing
and i hope that all the fans and
everybody that loves the nfl
will be proud of the game on sunday i
appreciate you giving me an answer to
the stupidest question i've admittedly
ever asked an nfl head coach but this is
truly brandon staley something that so
many fans are talking about and i even
just said about 10 minutes ago knowing
that you're coming on the program that
you know how how would you do something
like that what are you you what you get
telesco hooking up with mayok and you
and versace on a zoom and what and then
you kneel for three and a half hours in
front of the country i mean that is the
dumbest thing i've ever heard of but i
did i do have a coach who's playing this
game and i i wanted to put that in front
of you you know and present yeah i mean
i think um
you know for the for the nfl well i
think as you know you've been in the nfl
now um pretty much your your whole life
i mean what makes it so special is the
competition and the the level of
integrity and respect that that it
stands for and um certainly that's what
we're going to try and live up to this
sunday coach brandon staley thank you
for the times you've called in during
this regular season and uh for you and
the charger fateful i hope we have a
playoff conversation and many more to
come so thank you for the time and happy
new to you and yours thank you rich
happy new year thanks for having us you
got that's brandon staley the head coach
of the los angeles chargers
who is hanging up the phone and saying
that was the dumbest question i've ever
heard
so no tie that's not gonna happen yeah
no it's just but everyone sounds like
why wouldn't why wouldn't the chargers
and raiders do that
well it makes too much sense why does it
make sense because they both make the
playoffs but it doesn't matter that's
not what it's about it's about it's
about making the playoffs it's about
winning a championship
you can't i'm gonna let you in a little
secret
can't win the championship if you don't
make the playoffs yes but you can be
assured of making it by winning yourself
you don't have to care about the other
guy but if you but if you played a
winner you really mean what you're
saying are you playing devils
play to win you might lose
but if you played a tie
you guarantee yourself the win but how
do you do that though
by the way though
if this game goes to overtime i'm just
having fun
let's just say this if the game goes to
overtime
and tying does benefit you
right
and it does benefit you and you start
taking the air out of the ball to make
it
and you're on the other side
do you just
clearly let him do it
like what if
one team
[Music]
in overtime where overtime is reached
because
you know you're competing your asses off
and it's just an uh an awesome game and
it goes to overtime if sunday night
football goes to overtime and it's just
like hey if these teams end in a tie
they both make it
and you're trying to win
you're trying to win and you take six
seven minutes off the clock and kick a
field goal and miss and the other team
now has it
okay
do you just take a knee on it
to just make sure that you tie at this
point it benefits you to tie forget
about the fact that it benefits the
other team
what if you do that to take the air out
of it and give 40 seconds left to the
other team to win
and they use it to beat you
as opposed to just taking the tie and
saying screw it they use it to beat you
you're gonna kick one from 55 yards out
just to win
when the miss means you're in it anyway
but you're just spitting it your last
breath like the wrath of khan at the
other opponent i don't know what happens
that like that could be absolutely
the moment that this coach we just
chatted with is in
and you got to look your guys in the
locker room and say we're playing to win
that's all we're about this is too
exhausting
you win the game
you win the game it's a fascinating
good for this type of
conversation but when it comes down to
actually executing it and talking to a
man whose life is all about competition
and winning and creating that
environment for his team and his locker
room and his franchise what are you
gonna just take a knee for three and a
half hours yeah
plus all this talk about and i
appreciate him answering that question
but i kind of felt compelled to ask the
question that
everyone is talking about like they
should tie they should absolutely tie
why wouldn't they tie it's an easy thing
to tie they both in shouldn't they get
together and tie this whole thing and
then yeah without the idea of what's the
nuts and bolts of making that happen
i know
of course his answer should have been
like you're an idiot i'm hanging up the
phone now forget about me giving you
that parking spot
and never calling again i'm never
calling you guys hi
but it would be cool if they just played
for any time
well
if it if they just if they go at it on
sunday night and they just happen to tie
stop and it happens to go into overtime
that will be a fascinating conversation
between al and chris for the whole
country to see
because whoever wins the toss is going
to try and win the game
but what if they try and win the game
and they take a ton of time off and the
other team gets the ball back with just
two and a half minutes to go do they run
the risk of losing no no in a regular
time forget about the fact that the tie
would put the other team that you're
trying to beat in also you would play
for the tie at that point in time
because the tie gets you in gets you in
correct and it just happens to get the
other team in so you're playing for that
time my question is what if you play for
that tie
and then you have to punt
and the other team's got like 60 seconds
left does that guy return the punt for a
touchdown just like yeah you win and
you're right i hate saying
i spit my last
death
thank you very much that's uh that's the
wrath of khan
you know what i'm saying i i do like and
then and then the other team is kind of
like
has to understand that that's the way
the cookie does in fact crumble
hello what i'm praying for is like
23 20
raiders get the ball
they drive down the field daniel carlson
hits a field goal to send it to overtime
right and then it's going to be must-see
they have to send it to overtime because
the loss means they're out right they
have to try to win and somebody will try
to win in overtime the question is is
what happens if that doesn't materialize
and the other team gets the ball back
with a minuscule amount of time left
knowing the time gets them in do they
still try to win it and if they just try
to take the air out of the ball and give
it back to the other team for whom a tie
also
does get them in
do they try and win it just to say we're
in you're out
even
if we had taken a knee we'd both be in
and the steelers and they're faithful
are living and dying with every second
the problem is this is all great
conversation that is never going to
happen for two reasons one
competitors in the nfl will never
ever purposefully take a knee for the
other team and two the jaguars have to
beat the cults
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here